um i'm glad that we can have this
hour together indeed as you said
uh helga the world is a very different
place
compared to when we met last time in
september
and yes a virus that did not even exist
back then
has disrupted and dominated our work
your work
and ambassadors you have had to organize
a hell of a lot deliveries of medical
aid
the repatriation flights for stranded
europeans
you supported aid workers citizens and
business people
dealing with the lockdowns and the
travel restrictions
so you have been the face of european
solidarity and cooperation
around the world and i want to thank
you for all these efforts
[Music]
this work with our partners all around
the world this solidarity and
cooperation
is more important today than than it has
ever been
and i say this because the crisis
served as a very strong reminder of the
need
to tackle global challenges together
and of course it also exposed a number
of weaknesses
in the global system and it accelerated
many structural changes
whether geopolitical ecological
or mainly technological in nature
in short we cannot turn back the hands
of time the world after corona
will never look like the world we knew
before it
but our commitment to our values
and to our partners will remain as
steadfast as ever
and that was of course true regardless
of the outcome
of the us election last week but like
most of the world
i watched the elections intently i was
glued to the tv
and like many of you i became overnight
expert on voting tendencies in counties
across georgia pennsylvania and arizona
and i want to again warmly congratulate
president-elect joe biden and vice
president-elect kamala harris
who has just shattered multiple glass
ceilings in one go so
watching from afar there are two things
that struck me above all else
the first is the resilience
and the strength of democracy we saw
more people vote than ever before
we saw volunteer work volunteers working
around the clock
local officials communicating honestly
with citizens
and we saw media channels painstakingly
explaining the results
as they came in and of course
the perfect democracy does not yet exist
but i personally believe democracy
will emerge stronger from this election
and the second reflection is
that the u.s like many other parts in
of the world has also changed
over the last years and here again we
cannot turn back time
or go back to a world of before
i believe that divisions can always be
bridged
wounds can be healed but some shifts
in priorities and perceptions
run much deeper than one politician
or one administration and they will not
disappear
because of one election
so this of course has an impact on us
here in europe
and on the next chapter of the
transatlantic alliance
our alliance is based on shared values
and history
on a common belief in working together
to build a stronger more peaceful and
more prosperous world
and these goals will always endure
but in a changing global landscape
i believe it is time for a new
transatlantic agenda
fit for today's world and
i believe it is europe who should take
the initiative
with an offer to work together with the
new administration
to work on areas that can strengthen our
bilateral
and our multilateral partnerships and
this should cover
everything from security to
sustainability
from tech regulation to trade
from leveling the global economic
playing field
to strengthening global institutions
and these are not only eu
us issues and our alliance is not just
about
us it must be the backbone of a new
global alliance
it is about working with emerging powers
and like-minded partners
from africa to latin america from
australia
to democratic asia and far beyond
it is about working in our common
interest
for the common good
there are a number of areas where europe
is already taking the initiative
and we'll be ready to work closely with
the united states
and others over the next year and the
first and most pressing is obviously
overcoming this pandemic
in the face of the crisis some have
chosen to isolate
others have tried to use a difficult
situation
to strike geopolitical gains
we have chosen to lend a helping hand to
all those in need
we have sent tons of medical medical
equipment to china
in the early days of the pandemic we
were with the frontline doctors helping
syrians in refugee camps
we invested over 3 billion euros
in the western balkans to buy
ventilators testing kits and protective
equipment
and we have led the global response
putting cooperation over competition
and from the very outset we organized
the global response to coronavirus
we convened more than 40 countries to
collectively
raise over 16 billion euros four tests
for treatments
for diagnostics and for the research
towards a vaccine
this was an enormous experience and we
helped to set up
carvacs cobax is
the global initiative to create the
largest portfolio of vaccine candidates
in the world
we brought together 186 countries
but also ngos business leaders
philanthropists actually many of which
were from the united states
and together we are securing millions of
doses of future vaccines
for low-income countries because we know
no country can achieve this alone
but together we can
and we want to invite everyone to join
us we need to
pool our expertise we need to share our
resources
and we need to coordinate our approach
to tests and treatments
and vaccines and vaccinations that is
the moment now to do this
and actually this will be one of the
priority areas
for next year's global health summit
which prime minister khan and i will
convene as
part of the italian g20 presidencies
lessons learned and the look forward
the second obvious and crucial area
is protecting our climate and nature
europe is a pioneer in the fight against
climate change
and you know that we want to become the
first climate neutral continent in the
world by 2050
and i hope in december the european
council will agree
on our proposal for reducing emissions
by at least 55 by 2030
as compared to 1990 levels
and we can already see that our ambition
is not in isolation
china has now decided to become co2
neutral by 2060.
south africa has announced climate
neutrality by 2050.
japan and south korea have followed suit
and of course we look forward to the
united states rejoining the paris
agreement
as president-elect joe biden has
committed to
so in the months ahead we must all work
to raise the climate ambitions of other
countries
too we must first of all engage with the
economies of the g20
they are responsible for 80
of global greenhouse gas emissions
so next year the world will come
together in glasgow
for club 26 on climate
and the world will come together in
kunming
for cup 15 on biodiversity
these will be landmark moments in the
world's ability
to push back against climate change and
biodiversity destruction
and europe will be at the forefront of
brokering
ambitious commitments and i believe the
united states
is also well placed to support us i mean
given the remarkable work
going on in different american states
and cities and companies
and in civil society these events
will also be important moments for our
multilateral rules-based system
and the institutions that underpin them
we want to work with our partners to
strengthen them
be it in the united nations be it in the
who or the wto
we need strong institutions
backed by strong commitment from member
countries
our international system has been held
hostage for too
many years now so the time has come to
reverse the trend
to reform those institutions that need
reform
and to revive multilateral deals that
are essential for
common security to create new coalitions
on the most
pressing issues of our times
one such coalition is needed on the
digital world
this is an area where i believe
europe can take the initiative and
partner up with the us and others
we need to define a rule book
on the digital economy and society
covering everything from big data
to big tech from data used to data
privacy but also from infrastructure to
security
and i will just name a few fields
where this is particularly important
the first one is our relationship with
online platforms
online platforms have gained a huge
influence and economic power
and their behavior has an impact not
only on free and fair competition among
businesses
but also on our democracies
on our security and on the quality of
our information
and this immense power requires
adequate rules our values need to be
protected
online as well as offline and this means
at its most basic that what is
illegal offline should also be illegal
online
and should be pursued just as
effectively
and take illegal hate speech and
terrorist propaganda
in recent weeks we have seen once again
how urgent this
is we will propose a broad reform
with the digital services act it will
reach beyond our targeted proposal on
terrorist content and create
stronger rules for the removal of
all illegal content while protecting
free speech this is a very fine balance
and it will clarify the responsibilities
of online platforms
so to know their business customers
to be more transparent on how content
spreads and to show
how they respond to this
in parallel we are also proposing
a digital markets act
and this will set out tools to address
timely the economic power of gatekeeper
platforms
these gate keeper platforms will we have
to make sure that we protect fair
competition
and innovation and these will be the
rules for operating
in europe but it will be important
that and here i come back to the global
topic that our global partners
also raise their standards so the
european way on digital services and
markets
can be a model for others confronted by
the same challenges
and so it will become an important part
of our diplomacy
the second topic in the digital part is
for me data protection
from brazil to south korea our european
rules on personal data protection have
inspired
others to modernize their own privacy
rules
we must now put special focus
on the international transfer of data
particularly after the recent ruling of
the
european court of justice
and the third topic is a fair taxation
of the digital economy
many large digital companies are
emerging from the crisis
more profitable and with a larger market
share than ever before
well this is okay anyone who does
business in the single market
and thus benefits from our
infrastructure
from our education system or our social
system
is welcomed to make profits
but our social contract expects them
to pay appropriate taxes in order to
contribute
to this social market economy
and it cannot be that commercial giants
benefit enormously from our single
market
but failed to pay taxes where they
should
i think this undermines the acceptance
of the social market economy
and we will not longer tolerate this
and this creates an even greater urgency
to find an international agreement
on the taxation of digital businesses
and on global minimum taxation
our goal remains a consensus-based
solution at the oecd and g20 level
on both pillars of the global
discussions
but let there be no doubt
should an agreement fall short of a fair
tax
system europe will act
and the new deadline of mid
2021 must be and will be
the final one so should an arrangement
and an agreement fall short of a fair
tax system that provides long-term
sustainable revenues
we will come forward with our own
proposal
i think it is a matter of fairness
everyone must contribute their fair
share and particularly those
who are benefiting from this crisis
in other words the digital economy
should serve everyone
not just a privileged few and for this
we need global rules and international
cooperation
and europe must be the leading force
towards international cooperation on
these digital issues
ladies and gentlemen so this was a
bouquet
health climate digital reform of the
multilateral rules based systems
these are some of the indeed key areas
where i see europe can take the
initiative
and offer a positive a new agenda with
the united states
and again as we know we cannot
turn the clock back not on trade
not on ttip and we cannot go back to the
exact same agenda we had five years ago
we should not fall into that trap we
need a fresh approach
also because the world has changed and
so have the united states and
so has europe our
focus should be on providing
joint leadership to address the global
challenges of today
without being nostalgic for the world of
yesterday
and there is a lot more work we can do
on our bilateral trade issues on
standards on taxation
and many other areas we can make quick
progress
together with the administration and the
new congress
and there are so many compelling reasons
for the european union and the united
states
the two largest polls of free market
activity in the world
to work together
that is what we will do and at the same
time
we will continue to work on all our
partnerships whether they are easy
or they are complicated so take china
the eu-china relations are of
real strategic importance to both sides
and to the world
but this relationship is also one of our
most challenging and you have heard me
say
many times china is a negotiating
partner
an economic competitor and a systemic
rival all at once we have many
interests in common for example on
climate change
but we still have an unbalanced trade
and investment partnership
and long-standing issues on fair market
access
reciprocity and over capacity
and there is no doubt that we promote
very different systems of governance
and society and we must always continue
to call out human right abuses wherever
they are the european union
is fully committed to a genuine
result-oriented engagement with china
and indeed we made some breakthroughs at
our recent meeting
but we are also realistic we need to see
concrete results if we are to conclude
glued negotiations on an investment
partnership
concrete results are necessary
the point is that europe is ready to
work on all
of its partnerships whether with
neighbors
competitors or difficult negotiators
it is important for our own interests
and for strengthening global cooperation
for the common interest
but europe can only play its
full role in the world if it is
strong internally and if it takes care
of itself
so being geopolitical as you said helga
means understanding the links between
our domestic decisions and our external
action
and we have everything at our disposal
a unique single market and social market
economy
a position as the world's first trading
superpower and the world's second
currency
so we have to keep up the momentum on
all of our priorities
look at ourselves from completing the
banking union and capital markets union
to strengthening our industry to doing
more to strengthen our defence and
security and you name it
it means being assertive in defense of
fairness
for example whether through a carbon
board adjustment mechanism this will be
a big topic
or digital levy as we just discussed
the stronger more assertive we are
internally
the more we can achieve in the world and
that
is how geopolitical power is built
and nowhere will this internal strength
be more important
than in building a better world after
the crisis
i spoke about our global response to the
pandemic
now i would like to conclude about our
recovery
and how you can support it in your daily
work
around the world
over the next two years
governments around the world will spend
around
10 trillion euros for the recovery
and this is money that
we are borrowing from future generations
so we borrow now on capital markets
and we will have to give back in the
coming decades
but the choices we make today will
define the next generation's lives
our cherishes can and will shape the
economy that the next generation will
inherit
and for this reason our recovery plan
is called next generation eu and it's a
huge responsibility
we want to use it not only to recover
but to come out of the crisis with a
better economy
it has to be greener it has to be more
digital
and it has to be more resilient and thus
fit for the next generation
europe has chosen to invest 37
of next generation eu in projects
with a positive impact on the european
green deal
and we commit to invest the rest
only in projects that do no
significant harm
we will invest another 20 percent of
next generation
eu on digital projects on infrastructure
technology artificial intelligence data
and we will ensure the recovery is fair
for all
and makes our economies more resilient
to external shocks
this is a must ladies and gentlemen
to achieve all this we will need
allies and partners all across the world
and we need to draw on our strength to
make that happen
a united europe is a diplomatic power
that can make a difference on the
international stage
we have a clear understanding the new u
s
administration but also many countries
around the world
we all have a clear understanding that
global cooperation
needs to restart it is up to
us to take the initiative and we have
the best and most experienced team
to guide us through these uncharted
waters
i think for example and want to thank
our high representative vice president
joseph burrell
for his state's craft his statesmanship
and his diplomatic knowledge all these
skills will continue to be invaluable as
we enter this next chapter in global
affairs
his experience his skills
and his drive and they are impressive
and i also want to take this opportunity
to pay tribute to helga schmidt
she has helped shape the eas from
the ground up and she has been
the authority on eu foreign policy
for well well over a decade
from javier solana to joseph burrell
her advice has been precious
and her negotiating skills are an
inspiration to manny legendary
so she does not need luck in the next
chapter of her career
but i know you will join me in wishing
her
all the best so as she will
no doubt tell you wherever you are
posted
this is a moment for action
it is a moment to reach out and make
clear that europe is ready to engage
engage for recovery engage for
resilience
engage for reforms indeed
europe is ready long live europe
thank you
you